[Applause]
what we saw here was your wife and your
daughter in your new TV series and I I
wonder when I when I watch it how often
are you on the receiving end of that
mood this is my life story but ever
we're a little bit like that at home
true yes so how do you respond to it I
go upstairs switch on the television and
watch football I mean you do you do big
productions you've you've made so many
films and and it's it's big budgets and
it's a lot of people yeah and it's a lot
of stress how stressed are you I don't
stress how can is that simple everyday
stress well maybe I stress without
knowing it but I mean you really feel
you don't start now I don't stress I
think of you talk to anyone who work
with me they would say I'm the least
stressed on the crew I mean it's like
this if you stress at all it's in
getting the money to make the film Bay
go knocking on doors asking in it I want
to make a film can I have the money once
you've got the money if you have your
actors and you have your crew I feel
you've done the worst part of the job
making films is a wonderful way to live
and the money is not mine
I think the people stressing are the
people around you know why I'm serious
because if you think about that when you
film you'd never make a good film you
have to get that out of your head to me
it's like monopoly I mean I grew up I
was born in 1944 I mean the war was on
the edge of ending no now we're in the
South of England now we're in living in
the south
when we used to go to my grandma's that
would go past you know likes Tatsu sit
bombed to the ground streets bombed to
the ground but of course as a kid I
think about this now when you see war
zones but to us look like how can you
live there well if you're a kid of
course you can that's all you've ever
known
roof you know houses were no roofs and
you know cinemas that are not there
anymore so you couldn't avoid the war
and Portsmouth was the biggest Dockyard
in the world at the time and of course
it was bombed - how but since you since
you started working in in the business
in the entertainment business and your
first years was it they were in Britain
of course yeah you got to work with a
lot of big stars I mean who was the most
difficult do you think looking back well
I worked with a lot of difficult people
but the one who takes the biscuit was
awesome well I guess the actor yeah and
director and director and man the
Citizen Kane yes you know 23 years old
and still voted the best film ever I
think well what was your job what did I
was the assistant director to sell I
mean I was the one that stood in between
the director who all smiles hated and
took you know the problems both ways but
what made him he wasn't difficult to me
he was wonderful to me but he was
difficult to the photographer who he
could understand taking photographs the
director who he had no respect for
actually the makeup girl who did it too
hard on his face he had a wild temper
and he wasn't very well and he was
drinking every day all day and I said to
him what we why are you doing this he
said I need the money like everybody
else he has to live he had an old lady
as she
tantrum and did everything forms she
came up to me and said could he take a
longer lunch today Kannan he's gonna
meet a friend in his favorite restaurant
so I said all right off you go
but please don't be too long because
it's me that gets my head kicked in
three o'clock four o'clock five o'clock
he still doesn't come back the director
now is going berserk I think it was a
quarter to seven in walks Orson you know
and he was huge this you know just like
you think of him with the big hat or the
long scarf very kind of happy guy walked
in with this little old lady by side
I said Orson's here okay fine I went
into the back room that was his the
little room and said where the hell have
you been
you know I'm lucky to still be alive
he'd been to Paris
that's it private plane of course he did
this job he needed money I mean you were
gonna live like that to take a private
plane from Heathrow to Paris and back
but his favorite restaurants was that in
Paris it was in Paris so you know you
you ended up in Sweden almost by
accident totally by accident but what
was your first impression of Sweden
nightmare what was that it was a
nightmare I came to Sweden again as an
assistant director to work with Swedish
television on a children's drama and so
you keep to Stockholm
I came to Stockholm and I actually went
by taxi to Heathrow the taxi driver got
to say one thing he said I tell you
about Sweden the Sun never shines it's
got the highest suicide rate in the
world the women are beautiful it's the
center of pornography and I looked out
of the window and it's full of pine
trees and as we came into our land our
then in the 70s number one that's all I
could see pine trees nothing else of
pine trees but this time I got into the
taxi it was black the Sun had gone you
know it was from mid-afternoon so we
drive across calm and we eventually
stopped at the door of what to me look
like a kind of bar or a club and when we
actually walked in we were kind of on
the stage there were two people who
looked as though they were having sex
they probably weren't but we found they
probably are and it was a club that used
to be here called Chat Noir I think very
famous at the time so you know three
Englishmen in the more like Copenhagen I
think
well I tell you what it's it's not all
so what does look no no no no agents
would not say shut no ID and also it's a
very decent theater it was very decent
together in Stockholm on that night
because we were like what in house name
so we were sort of throw and pine trees
dark every woman that we looked at
coming out of England looked stunningly
beautiful and we were now in the center
of pornography it was like the taxi
driver you know got everything right but
we came back in the summer to the most
wonderful country that I've ever been to
the Sun never saw it's a very different
thing isn't it ah so different and I
mean I fell in love before we move on
yeah I mean I could speak Swedish with
you or I can't speak Swedish but but
what's your thing with the Swedish
language because you understand it you
know as you never speak it no how bad is
it my Swedish oh this is appalling I
mean you can't live in a home like mine
where you've only got to say one Swedish
word and everyone bursts out laughing
just sort of feel confident but also
there is another thing I know when
Helena when Helena is really angry as
something that I do she switches
immediately to Swedish so when Helena's
talking Swedish to me you know I'm in
trouble
left
bigger Romney or dupe are a more
no or structures Patel feeder Thank You
Colin hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe